alexander lukashenko the man who ruled
belarus for 26 years
seems to be clenching his iron fist even
further
young student protesters are dragged and
bundled into vance by mass men
let them go some protesters say
but their voices are ignored if these
arrests were meant to deter
demonstrations
that didn't happen women
and students in their thousands soon
marched across the capital minsk
in defiance we've got the words we are
tired of the police state here
they come to the universities they grab
people at their doorsteps
they're already starting to come to
schools what's next kindergartens
there have been thousands of arrests
since lukashenga claimed a landslide
victory
in last month's disputed elections the
allegations of crackdown on journalists
and torture and beatings of protesters
the law hasn't been observed in our
country in a long time
first the elections were rigged then the
people who came out to protect their
rights were beaten
murdered arrested this prominent
opposition activist who was detained
last month
appeared in poland she says she was
forced by the government to leave
belarus
or face arrest they came to the reman
center where i was isolated
they gave me a hat a mask and took me
out of prison they made me lie on the
back seat and they drove me away
the main opposition challenger also in
exile swetlana chinoskaya
warned russia from meddling by
supporting the president
they have to understand that only the
belarusians have the right to decide how
to deal with this problem
our people are friendly with each other
and we're not going to cut any ties with
russia
but interference in our internal matters
is of course unacceptable
another major demonstration is planned
for sunday as protesters
keep the pressure on a precedent
determined to cling to power
priyanka gupta al-jazeera